Justin Timberlake is headed to the Super
Bowl halftime show but is Janet gonna
crash it Justin Timberlake finally
confirms what we told you guys a month
ago he will headline the Super Bowl
halftime show
he's bringing sexy back to football's
biggest stage and made the announcement
on Twitter with the help of his pal
Jimmy Fallon excuse me sir do you have
the time I was going to ask you sir do
you have the job I do have the time you
do have time I do have time you do have
to do have time you do have to I do have
the Super Bowl he do have time oh I'm so
here for this that man knows how to
entertain and this will of course be
JT's third time at the big show and a
lot of people are already speculating
that he'll bring NSYNC out but folks are
also wondering 14 years after that
infamous incident could Janet Jackson
rejoin Justin after Super Bowl while a
source close to Janet tells et that miss
Jackson if you're nasty has not been
approached by JT or his team but she's
open to it quote if Justin or his team
did reach out Janet would perform with
him again in a minute an NFL
spokesperson told us it doesn't comment
on speculation but quote there's no band
good because I think Jana needs a redo
can I get a hashtag justice for Janet
all right so whether Super Bowl 52 will
be the site of a Justin and Janet
reunion remains to be seen but JT made
it clear what we won't see at any point
in the ask do they say hey just the last
time there's a little wardrobe thinking
we make sure that doesn't happen
and the long as we're doing that then
you're good with you don't happen this
time there was a little bit of that but
but yeah I think um ya know Mike that's
not going to happen the 10 time Grammy
winner said he's already studied past
halftime shows and don't expect him to
pull a gaga because he is not flying
well you better pull a Beyonce and bite
your boys for that NSYNC reunion we
deserve Plus Lance Bass told us the guys
are ready to go if they're asked so
Justin please all right speaking of
buddies the cast of The Walking Dead got
together to celebrate 100 episodes and
thousands of zombies killed are Leeanne
Aguilera caught up with star Andrew
Lincoln who reflected on that season 8
time jump and of course 100 episodes of
blood and gore we are here celebrating
100 episodes of The Walking Dead how's
the real is that for you right now it is
well the show itself the fact that I
fight zombies for a living is surreal
enough but yes 100 episodes it feels
like a hundred years of slaying zombies
it's incredible when you're not filming
the episodes what do you not miss it all
about the goo and the blood and the guts
well I was actually just two days ago
head set foot covered in blood and it's
the ride home afterwards it's being
stopped by the cops that is a bit
unfortunate but um you've been stopped
by the cops while you were covered in
blood and unfortunately was like season
1 so that no one knew what the show was
so they checked the chunk of my car it
was crazy but fortunately I think that
the cops know us now so and so I tend to
just drive home looking like Carrie the
season 8 premiere and it jumps in time a
lot and a lot of people are not sure
what's real what's not for the fans who
have just watched it how would you
explain it to them what happened in this
premiere it is it's it's offering up
alternative futures I'm gonna give
that's as much as I'm probably going to
give but basically there is a future
that looks to be seven years five years
to seven years on where Judith has grown
up and then there's another future that
seems to be where Rick Grimes is dying
so I wonder what's going to happen give
us a little hint
do you know which ending is real I do
are you happy with it I'm really
concerned about the ending he's
concerned how I am alright guys that's
it for today thank you for watching if
you like what you saw prove it like and
share this video and while you're at it
hit that subscribe button and we'll see
you guys tomorrow Jake you got the Super
Bowl